the channel framework is a new
experimental technology in version 11
I'll start with a quick demo of the
framework then tell you a little bit
when you want to use the framework and
when you would better be served by other
existing technologies then I'll briefly
touch on a few advantages of the pops up
or publish/subscribe messaging which is
used by the framework then quickly show
how to customize the framework to suit
your needs
and finish off with a quick rundown of
some farm applications so what does the
channel framework do first of all it
allows any device that is capable of
making an HTTP request to talk to your
current while from language session no
matter where the device or your current
computer is located the basic building
block is a channel listener I'll now
start listening on the channel named
channel they also set up a display for
incoming messages when a new message
arrives this dynamic will update now
let's send a message to our listener the
simplest of course is to do it directly
from the language in this case I send a
message from the same session but I can
do exactly the same on any other
computer my laptop or from cloud hotel
now let's do something more interesting
this is a URL of my listener the some
additional message appended I'll go to a
web browser and make a web request as
you see the listener receives the
request and updates the display you get
the idea but to drive the point home
let me also cook up a curl command and
send a message from a terminal session
again the terminal session can be
anywhere on the internet and my listener
receives the message and back to my
Wolfram language session I can see all
messages that arrived so far construct
the data set what messages created time
series whatever the messages are already
in my wall from which
so I can do whatever I want with them
now you don't always meet this new
technology if you just want to do some
math or just store your messages you can
do that through the channel framework
too but there are simpler ways to do
that but when you really need a channel
framework is when you want to send your
data to your current or from language
session or when you want to process your
data asynchronously in your current
session that's where the framework
becomes indispensable or when you want
to do the job in some other specific
foreign language session made on some
another machine or a number of machines
and that's when you can use the
framework to with pops up or
publish/subscribe there is another
server somewhere out there in this case
is channel broker dot Wolfram cloud comm
and by sending messages through that
server you can't care less which machine
speaks which language which drivers are
needed to talk to which device or how
many machines are listening to your
message or how many other machines are
talking on your channel all these
complexities are abstracted away for you
you just talk to a channel that is a URL
and listen on a shadow and there is
nothing more to it now in my first
example the listener did nothing but
accumulate data that was the default to
listener handler but you can also define
your own handlers for messages here I
create a channel that prints incoming
messages to the messages window and
because the handler is already defined
on a channel I don't need to repeat it
when starting a listener when this
listener started it queried the server
got the handler and now knows what to do
with messages it receives
I'm sending hello to the channel and
it's printed here and we also made it
super easy for you to override the
default handler which you can do simply
by giving a second argument to chair
listen instead of printing a message
this listener speaks it here we go as
you can imagine this simple system gives
you a tremendous flexibility in great
many applications to numerous to be
covered here in any detail but if there
will be only one point you carry from
this stock it should be this if a system
can make an HTTP request it can also
communicate with your Wolfram language
session
now I will just rush through some of the
examples that we worked out for you and
give you a link to the code in the end
you can send data remotely from one wall
from language session and plot the data
dynamically in another session or send
the data from an arduino eun and use
your foreign language session as a
dashboard or remotely evaluate your code
on another machine or a number of
machines that give you access all set up
your own chat system or create your own
wall from instant messaging we call it
rim client all make your foreign
language session speak your incoming
emails a hook up to Amazon lambda or an
IFFT channel and much more and here the
links I promised examples is the code
and the function
overview hope you enjoy the new channel
framework thank you